[Music]  nothing says next-level like an  engagement ets confirmed that after 14  months of dating 68 year-old David  Foster popped the question to katharine  mcphee and she said yes it happened  under the stars on a mountain in  anacapri while the two have been  vacationing in Italy  it's Katherine's second marriage David's  fifth he told us his 37 year old  daughter Sarah approves of her 34 year  old soon-to-be stepmom she said we just  want someone that's gonna treat him well  and that cares about him and I think  he's with someone right now that really  does if whoever you're with gets along  with your children it's just such a  bonus that's what I'll hope for for the  next 20 years anticipating the reaction  Katherine tweeted this gift this morning  well play Katherine well played  [Music]